Внаслідок війни Росії проти України понад 100 тисяч українських споживачів
залишаються без підключення до газорозподільних систем
і понад 600 тисяч - без підключення до електроенергії,
стверджують українські урядовці. Через загрозу ракетних ударів
опалювальний сезон цього року може стати найскладнішим
за всі роки незалежності. Можливі відключення газу та електроенергії.
Це труби, по яких газ надходить до споживачів в Україні.
Оператор газотранспортної системи відремонтує частини газогонів,
які були пошкоджені в результаті бойових дій. Та через війну зробити це
на всій території України -  неможливо.
Наразі у нас є декілька проблем, де ми не можемо повністю провести роботи.
Це зона активних бойових дій або окуповані території. Так наразі в нас нема
можливості постачати газ до Луганської та Донецької областей,
а також на південь Запорізької області. Але ми маємо надію, що після звільнення
цих територій ми зможемо оперативно провести роботи
і відновити газопостачання до наших споживачів.
Обійтися без імпортного газу цьогоріч також не вдасться.
Тож "Оператор ГТС" вже створює потужності для цього.
Ми створили потужності по імпорту газу з Європи. Наразі вони складають
54 млн кубічних метрів газу на добу.
Якщо помножити на 30 днів, то це означає, що в нас є технічна можливість
імпортувати в Україну близько 1,5 мільярди кубічних метрів на місяць.
Та чи вистачить газу самій Європі, щоб ще й Україна могла у них закупити?
Експерти кажуть, що європейський газовий ринок збалансований.
І на сьогодні у газосховищах ЄС вже зберігається понад 70 мільярдів кубічних метрів газу.
Насправді газу вистачить як для країн Європейського Союзу, так і для України.
Принаймні про це свідчать статистичні дані. За 7 місяців поточного року,
незважаючи на 40% падіння обсягів російського газу, Європейський союз
демонструє доволі оптимістичні показники по накопиченню газу у сховищах.
Принаймні показники по наповненості сховищ ЄС кращі за минулорічні
на 3 мільярди кубічних метрів природного газу. Це пов’язано з тим,
що обсяги споживання усіма категоріями споживачів ЄС
природньо зменшилися за 7 місяців на 22%.
Україна вже три місяці готується до різних сценаріїв опалювального сезону.
Уряд створив спеціальний штаб, зараз готують достатню кількість запасів газу,
вугілля та перевіряють готовність енергогенеруючих підприємств та інфраструктури.
Станом на сьогодні Україна вже має 11,3 мільярдів метрів кубічних газу.
Всього з початку року було закачано майже 3 мільярди кубометрів блакитного палива.
Створено можливості для фізичного реверсу газу з Європи.
Попри воєнні дії, видобуток газу державною компанією "Укргазвидобування"
майже не зменшився. "Нафтогазу" поставлене завдання до початку
опалювального сезону мати у сховищах 19 мільярдів метрів кубічних газу.
Експерти кажуть, що Україна може спожити цієї зими максимум
14-15 мільярдів кубометрів газу. Та обов’язково потрібно враховувати і воєнні ризики.
У будь-якому випадку потрібно мати ресурс газу, який замістити у випадку
розгерметизації магістральних газопроводів. Також залишається ризик
різкого зменшення обсягів прокачування російського газу через українську
газотранспортну систему. Це означає, що потрібно в українській газотранспортній
системі мати достатньо природного газу для підтримки тиску в усіх газогонах.
Інакше будуть зупинені газорозподільні станції. Відтак газопостачання
у міста і райони буде залишатися під загрозою.
Щомісяця Україна може відкладати ще по одному мільярду кубометрів газу
власного видобутку. А решту - імпортувати з Європи. Що ж до запасів вугілля,
то Україна вже накопичила півтора мільйона тонн. А до початку опалювального
сезону планує вийти на цифру понад два мільйони тонн. Цього має вистачити.
Та головна загроза для проходження опалювального сезону - військова.
Головна проблема, яка може трапитися взимку в Україні з опалювальним сезоном
- це російські ракети. Себто в нас достатньо газу, в нас достатньо вугілля,
в нас немає жодних проблем з постачанням енергоресурсу, в нас немає проблем
з генерацією електрики до моменту, поки наші теплоелектростанції,
теплоелектроцентралі фізично існують.
Уряд та місцева влада відновлюють котельні, ремонтують труби та теплоелектроцентралі,
які постраждали від війни, купують мобільні генератори тепла та електрики.
Вже виділили майже 300 мільйонів гривень на ремонти трьох ТЕЦ
у Чернігові, Кременчуці та Охтирці.
Щоб підготуватися до сценарію відключення газу та електрики,
українцям радять встановлювати автономні системи опалення,
переходити з газових на твердопаливні котли, використовувати
для опалення дрова чи вугілля.
Йде велика кількість ремонтів, велика кількість відновлень котелень,
велика кількість відновлень по теплоелектроцентралям, особливо там,
де вони постраждали від війни. Йде велика робота, щоб відновити
постачання до тих будинків, де зараз постачання перервано.
А щоб позбутися російського газового шантажу Європа вирішила скоротити
на 15% його споживання. Україна теж готова зробити свій вагомий внесок,
бо експорт української електрики може замінити газ,
який зараз спалюють європейці для генерування електрики.
Українська електроенергія сьогодні є прямою заміною російського газу.
Технічно ми вже могли б збільшити експорт нашої електроенергії
до 1,5-1,7 ГВт. Це може замінити до 5-6 мільярдів кубометрів російського газу.
Наші газові сховища - найбільші у Європі, і ми готові надати 12 мільярдів кубометрів
для зберігання європейських стратегічних запасів.
Тож попри усі проблеми і військові загрози Україна готується не лише
до власного опалювального сезону, а вже цієї зими готова допомогти
європейським країнам підвищити надійність газопостачання
і сприяти заміщенню російського газу.